abordables. Mais est-ce que
ce sera suffisant ?
Olivier Bachand.
- Alors que des familles
vont se retrouver à la rue dans
quelques jours, le gouvernement
Legault sort le chéquier.
On annonce deux partenariats :
des investissements de
395 millions de dollars
pour le logement.
ANDRÉE LAFOREST, ministre, Aff.
municipales et Habitation, Qc
- Ce sont 3000 nouveaux
logements abordables et sociauxx
qui seront rendus disponibles
à court terme et à moyen terme.
- Québec va confier 350 millions
au Fonds de solidarité de la FTQ
et au Mouvement Deuvement Deuves
pour la construction de
2000 logements sociaux
et abordables dans
un horizon de trois ans,
et 45 milllions iront
au Fondaction de la CSN
pour la construction de
1000 logements en copropriété
d'ici cinq ans. Ils seront
vendus en formule coopérative,
25 % sous le prix du marché.
GENEVIÈVE MORIN, présidente-
directrice générale Fondaction
- Ce coût réduit des
ménages à revenus modestes ou
moyens d'accéder à une première
propriété abordable.
- Le gouvernement Legault
affirme que ces initiatives
vont permettre de rattrapper
le retard constaté
dans la construction
de logements sociaux
à son arrivée au pouvoir.
- Avec l'annonce d'aujourd'hui,
on va dépasser les 15 000
construits dans 2-3 ans,
ça, c'est certain.
- La CAQ n'a pas livré
la marchandise.
- Mais le FRAPRU est déçu
du bilan du gouvernement.
VÉRONIQUE LAFLAMME, Front action
populaire en réaménag. urbain
- La promesse électorale,
c'était de livrer
les 15 000 logements sociaux
déjà prévus dans AccèsLogis
à son arrivée en poste.
Au moment où on se parle,
c'est à peu près le tiers
des logements qui ont été
effectivement livrés.
- Par ailleurs, Québec et Ottawa
pourraient s'entendre d'ici
quelques jours concernant
le Fonds national de co-
investissement pour le logement.
Lundi, Radio-Canada rapportait
que les deux gouvernements
négocient depuis quatre ans
un processus d'octroi
des fonds, ce qui met en péril
la construction et la rénovation
de près de 6000 logements
sociaux dans la métropole.
- Nous, ce qu'on a négocié
avec le fédéral, c'était
que la SCHL octroyait
rapidement les montants.
Maintenant, on attend après
la SCHL, là. C'est pas nous.
- Une déclaration
qui surprend à Ottawa.
SORAYA MARTINEZ FERRADA, secr.
parlem. du ministre du Logement
- Mais il n'y a absolument rien
qui empêche Québec aujourd'hui
d'autoriser le versement de
ces fonds à ces promoteurs
et ces organismes qui
ont ces projets.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Cette question-là
doit absolument se régler
le plus rapidement possible,
au plus tard avant le début
de la campagne électorale.
- Un accord permettrait
de financer une quinzaine
de projets à brève échéance,
des logements qui sont loin
d'être un luxe dans un marché
de plus en plus inabordable.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Mon